hunter biden's laptop was discovered at
a repair shop there was a ton of
compromise on it a ton of evidence of a
whole slew of crimes personal crimes
sexual crimes financial crimes
and this was blacked out you wouldn't
hear about it in the mainstream media
you weren't allowed to post about it on
social media you weren't allowed to
privately message it on social media and
now
how many days has it been
it's now it's been
532 days since that story broke since
that story was denied by the
establishment media now
532 days later
cnn is admitting okay it was real
so there's a lot of issues that the
justice department has looked into
including of course
this laptop that
on the right wing has featured a lot of
a lot of stories about about hunter
biden we know the fbi has possession of
it and that they believe it is his
laptop that the contents of it are his
thank you cnn thank you for telling us
532 days later what we've all known from
the beginning
namely that the laptop is obviously real
it's full of a ton of photos of hunter
biden
it's got all his photos all of these
frankly the emails are more damning than
the photos because it shows
extraordinary political corruption
financial crimes not just from hunter
but implicating the whole biden family
and yet
when the story broke we were told
that this was
disinformation russian
propaganda and disinformation here's an
article article in breitbart 15
media personalities who immediately came
out and said this was a total lie msnbc
executive producer kyle griffin
said
this is not censorship
facebook is under no obligation to allow
a disputed report that appears to
contain disinformation to spread on
their platform so the executive producer
at msnbc said oh it's really good in the
weeks before this presidential election
that we're censoring damaging content
about one of the candidates the
publisher of inc said basically the same
thing no serious journalist should fall
for this disinformation why'd you hot
ali at the daily beast this is russian
disinformation meant to harm our
democracy shouldn't be given platforms
uh truthfulfiction.com brooke binkowski
uh it's it's easy to see who's committed
to pushing known kremlin disinformation
it's known she not even that she didn't
know if it was accurate or not she knew
for a fact it was disinformation
nbc news did the same thing they're
hacked materials part of a
disinformation campaign
ben rhodes at msnbc it's disinformation
washington post's max boot he's a fake
republican who he's a democrat but he
pretends to be a republican at the
washington post he said the right to
spread false russian disinformation
about american political leaders on
social media is not the hill i would
choose to die so he's making the
affirmative claim this is false
the the the
laptop the hard drive it's false it's
not real the list goes on and on we
don't have time to go through all of
them and they were completely wrong they
were
at the v at the very least they were
completely wrong probably they were
lying
and now 532 days later after biden's
been in office for more than a year now
we can admit absolutely it's true
i'm glad you like that clip now you got
to subscribe ring the bell get all the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you